most people know that I get threatened a
lot on this channel people don't like it
when you expose them I suggest you use
the money you got from pumping your
patreon to hire a good lawyer you're
gonna need it so scammers saying that
they're gonna go after me is something
that I've long been desensitized to
coffeezilla nobody knows anything about
his family because they don't have the
resources I have but what we don't talk
about a lot is that the opposite is also
true when victims of scams learn what's
been done to them the scammer very often
becomes the target of a lot of personal
threats and honestly most of them seem
to take the same approach I do you
unfortunately have to ignore it because
99 of the time internet threats are just
that threats which never go beyond the
screen but this video is a reminder that
every now and then someone will take it
all away we're talking today about Aiden
platersky a scammer who taunted his
victims with flashy cars and took their
money until it was too late and he was
kidnapped beaten and ransomed for three
million dollars leading up to this video
with which I will warn you may be
disturbing everything that happened is
my fault I'm not going to put the blame
on anybody else I'm not gonna try to put
the building on anybody else feel
humiliated feel disgusted in my actions
I feel disgusting what I did after 2021
I feel like
a lot of it was illegal all these guys
that are owed the money
I'm gonna do what I can do to make it
right I'm gonna call each and every one
of you individually what you just saw is
a man who used to be called the crypto
King by forbes.com who took in 40
million dollars via a Ponzi scheme and
never repaid his victims in this video
he appears to be apologizing for those
actions but now that he's free he says
he had no choice now we first learned
about the kidnapping back in March when
Aiden platersky's father claimed that
Aiden was kidnapped but many people
including myself didn't really know what
to make of these claims because no
evidence existed besides an interview
which was filed in court the father says
that his son was taken they basically
held him for approximately three days
drove him around to various parts of
Southern Ontario beat him tortured him
allowed him to make specific phone calls
approximately two or three days later he
was released with the threat that he
needed to come up with some money fast
specifically three million dollars but
this week we found out that this kid
napping was very much real and that five
men were arrested and charged with
kidnapping and we know that allegedly
one of the kidnappers Akil Haywood
actually knew Aiden quite well because
he invested with him court records show
Haywood lost more than 700 thousand
dollars investing with platersky and in
another twist he was appointed as an
inspector in plattersky's bankruptcy
proceeding that's right one of the
kidnappers was one of flaturski's
victims who presumably watched him post
luxury cars and private jets to social
media until he had had enough and as one
of the bankruptcy inspectors he had
access to special kinds of information
about platersky possibly including the
fact that some of the trustees thought
platersky was hiding assets do you
believe that he's hiding assets from you
I have reason to believe that he is
still hiding assets yes so Haywood
likely knew plattersky wasn't sharing
everything and likely knew other people
in the case were hiding information too
like Colin Murphy one of the fundraisers
for this Ponzi scheme in January he
wiped his phone of all the data which he
was asked for and he had a very bad
explanation for why do you wiped your
phone before you know knowing that they
needed what was on it I keep a super
sense of stuff on there with my
girlfriend and um it's funny because uh
this Norman group guy
he wants uh he's saying oh I'm hiding
this information and blah blah blah and
he doesn't realize that I've been like
I've been keeping stuff uh to give to
somebody I just didn't know if he was
the right person ah dang I was about to
give you guys all the evidence I I was
trying to get it to you and then I I
swiped my phone for no reason
um yeah this this may be one of the most
transparent ways to hide evidence just
wipe it before and go I had a girlfriend
guys can't hold me accountable and my
point is these details suggest that
Haywood might have believed that
platersky was hiding assets that he
could get that the court simply couldn't
although it's worth saying I'm
definitely not defending what Haywood
did kidnapping him because not only is
it completely wrong it quickly came out
that Haywood isn't some misguided
vigilante for justice or something uh
given what he did next he seems about as
horrible Haywood is also charged with
threatening an official from Grant
Thornton who's overseeing the
proceedings for two million dollars in
crypto currency the accounting firm said
Haywood resigned as an inspector Grant
Thornton said we've been cooperating
with police and have maintained open
lines of communication we cannot comment
any further as this is an active
investigation wow you heard that right
not only did Haywood threaten the
scammer he threatened the bankruptcy
lawyers in the case and wanted a bunch
of money from them which is really
playing both sides in a creative way
I've got to say and my point is look
it's not like he was looking for the
amount he was owed which is allegedly
seven hundred forty thousand dollars he
was looking for millions of dollars as a
Payday so no one in this situation is
particularly great and of course since
then him and his co-conspirators now
face kidnapping charges but what I do
find very confusing is that all of the
crimes being passed around here like a
game of hot potato the one person not
being criminally charged in this
situation
is Aiden platersky himself the original
scammer in this whole situation that
started this all he lied to all those
people said he was this great uh
cryptocurrency Forex Trader allegedly
stole tens of millions of dollars spent
most of it on cars private jets and
expensive houses and he's not being
charged like I'm so surprised by this
this case is very reminiscent of another
story that we've just recently did with
Ted zafranco who promised these amazing
Forex trades but just ran a big Ponzi
instead and not only am I surprised by
the size of these Ponzi schemes and that
plateroski did something very similar he
invested only two percent of the 40
million he took in but I'm also
surprised by how blatant of a fraud this
is and incidentally the similarities
don't stop there with our last story
remember Ted safranco claimed he was
also attacked by would-be creditors and
so this pattern of crypto or Forex
scammers isn't going away anytime soon
nor are the legions of upset victims who
are pissed both that they got robbed and
that most of these people face little to
any criminal charges and so it's easy to
see why they're frustrated although I
have to say that I disagree with the
method kidnapping someone who scammed
you and ransoming them for money in some
kind of scammer Uno reverse card is not
a good idea and getting an apology from
them when you've beaten them up isn't
doing anyone a service so for ethical
reasons human reasons and stay out of
jail reasons Maybe
don't do this don't do it sounded a
little half-hearted coffee
what's next please drink responsibly I
don't know
constantly get threats so I sympathize
with the guy and don't do it is the
right answer but
I don't know but what well I don't I
don't know I get it I guess I mean it's
wrong but I get it
but it's clearly wrong and look Haywood
sucks but I get wanting to screw the guy
who screwed you but I can't say that
because it is wrong and the impulse is
wrong and I didn't want to put this in
but like this Aiden guy is horrible I
went to his Instagram to reach out for
comment and I saw what he's posting it's
all you know super cars private jets
it's a middle finger to all the victims
and if I lost money to that guy I'd be
pissed too wow coffee you got an edge I
didn't think you had it in you no I mean
I wouldn't do anything and I wouldn't
change what I said don't do it is the
right thing but
sometimes the right thing feels what
hopeless inadequate sisa being
pointless this conversation is pointless
I'm done talking about it
good you got anything on TV uh I hate
when you put my show on come on change
the channel put something else on oh
sure speaking of new topics I've got
just the thing that'll cheer you up
I found this new Creator you're gonna
love this copy very avant-garde stuff
I'm telling you future of entertainment
[Laughter]
gang gang gang gang
I ask you so good balloon
pretty great huh
oh thank you sir what is the noise again
[Music]